bonfort nous sommes le lundi 9 novembre
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal comme
chaque jour nous revenons sur votre
actualité locale accompagnés de nos
invités mais aussi des journalistes de
la rédaction commence tout de suite avec
les titres de cette édition à versailles
une voiture électrique autonome et
connectée a parcouru les rues du centre
ville
une expérience grandeur nature inédite
cette voiture du futur son conducteur
mobilise les constructeurs 27
associations réclament l'organisation
d'un débat public sur l'aménagement du
plateau de saclay elle s'inquiète de
l'avenir du site et des développements
envisagés nous ferons le point avec ses
représentants invité du journal
et enfin bois d'arcy vient d'organiser
son premier festival de la bande annonce
parlant du rendez-vous l'animateur
vincent perrot nous revenons sur
l'événement avec sephora namani et pour
commencer cette édition une triste
nouvelle le club de football de trappes
est en deuil l'attaquant de l'équipe
senior samba sissoko 20 ans l'un des
meilleurs joueurs du championnat de
promotion d'honneur est décédé dans un
accident de la route dans la nuit de
samedi à dimanche dans la zone
d'activités de trappes
la voiture aurait perdu le contrôle aux
alentours de 23 heures sur l'avenue
georges politzer les trois autres
personnes présentes dans la voiture ont
également été blessées conséquence les
matchs de football programmée ce
dimanche dans la ville ont été ont été
reportés on écoute les réactions du
président du club mustapha la barre
larbaoui ma réaction en fait elle est
évidemment celle de quelqu'un
d'extrêmement affecté affecté comme
tous les gens de trappes parce que dans
cette affaire la famille très très
affectée mais ça je crois que tout le
monde peut le comprendre quand il ya un
drame aussi terrible pour un enfant
fauché dans faucher six jeunes par la
mort tout ne peut comprendre que la
famille soit extrêmement affecté que ses
copains sont affectés tous les gens qui
le connaissaient du club de foot et et
les amis de la des quartiers soient
affectés voilà donc on est tous très
touchés très peinés et voilà et ça je
crois que tout le monde peut comprendre
ce que c'est que un enfant qui part très
tôt fauché par la mort est violemment
pour le coup et bien sûr toutes nos
pensées notre soutien vont à la famille
de samba cissokho une collecte a été
lancée sur internet pour financer ses
obsèques plus de 3000 euros ont été
collectés juste avant l'enregistrement
de cette émission pouvez participer sur
cette cagnotte litchi qui s'appuie
s'affiche en bas de votre écran est à
présent un tout autre sujet vendredi
l'institut pour la transition
énergétique vd comme installé à
versailles-satory attestée dans le
centre-ville de la cité royale son
véhicule bi mode c'est la première fois
qu'une voiture électrique autonome et
connectée parcouraient les rues d'un
centre ville nous étions sur place
les images sont signés camille lambert à
première vue rien de très futuriste
c'est à l'intérieur que cette voiture
bi-mode cache ses innovations caméras
capteurs équipements électroniques et
ordinateurs dans le coffre permet à ce
véhicule de se conduire tout seul bazin
ne touche à rien c'est la voiture
répondu complètement tout seul
jaurès uniquement vigilante la voiture
élaborée en près de neuf mois par
l'institut vd comme située à larissa y
ait d'autres partenaires comme les deux
constructeurs automobiles français est
testé pour la première fois à
l'extérieur
apple et bimode elle peut se conduire
manuellement comme un véhicule
automatique puis passer en délégation de
conduite avec apporte tout autour
d'elles suzanne muzion à 360° tout
autour de la voiture à l'afad englobant
une fois que j'ai perçu mon
environnement j'ai besoin de savoir où
je suis c'est pourquoi on utilise des
techniques de localisation du liban à
versailles ce conte est surtout en mode
délégation de conduite
elle détecte elle même les obstacles
comme les piétons grâce aux informations
de localisation reçu sur son ordinateur
sur un parcours de 2 km à versailles des
feux rouges ont été équipés afin de
transmettre henry fils et informations à
la voiture des signaux qui ont villes
peuvent être brouillés par les immeubles
en réalité ces bd comme qui a équipé un
nos capteurs sur les rouges donc
financièrement c'est neutre pour nous
c'est veiller comme qui assume ses coûts
neuf mois environ un million d'euros et
l'action de 40 partenaires ont été
nécessaires à l'institut pour élaborer
ces véhicules renault nous a donné en
fait et ce qui est vraiment une première
mondiale leurs plateformes
autonome et puis ensuite on a équipé des
technologies cette voiture qui devient
un véhicule rêver comme pour lequel tous
les laboratoires et les uns du skal
peuvent se bloquer ou clavier leur
technologie pour avancer tous ensemble
la voiture est encore en phase de test
elle ne devrait pas faire son apparition
sur le marché public avant au moins une
dizaine d'années le temps peut être que
la législation soit aussi mise à jour
car pour l'instant tout véhicule en
mouvement doit avoir un conducteur
responsable commandes et ce matin le
secrétaire d'état chargé de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche thierry mandon étaient
présents au commissariat de l'énergie
atomique de saclay pour inaugurer la
première pierre d'un nouveau bâtiment le
hisser aux infrastructures pour les
sciences du climat et de l'environnement
ce site est destiné à rassembler au même
endroit des personnels et instruments
scientifiques du laboratoire des
sciences du climat et de l'environnement
composé des chercheurs du cea du cnrs ou
encore de l'ue vs qu aujourd'hui 320
personnes travaillent sur ces divers
lieux le site devrait être livré fin
2007 pour un budget total de 36 millions
d'euros
écoutez les précisions recueillies par
mélanie potiche c'est un bâtiment qui va
permettre de favoriser les échanges
les échanges entre les scientifiques de
différentes thématiques et qui aussi il
ya des projets de pouvoir accueillir des
start up et puis de favoriser les
échanges entre les sciences du climat au
sens physique mais aussi avec la
dimension biologique avec la dimension
des sciences humaines et sociales donc
de pouvoir favoriser ces échanges qui
sont importants pour l'étude du
changement climatique c'est du gagnant
gagnant
parce que bon on l'avait entendu ya des
chercheurs qui sont très renommé donc ça
rejaillit sur une image de lui en citer
un puisqu'il ya quatre ans chercheur
drame historique et évoqué la sortie
mais qu'ils sont religieux la murcie en
onassis dont 4 ici et nous allons à
présent parler du plateau de saclay avec
nous au plateau ce soir claudine parayre
président de l'association louis
écologie bonsoir à vous et michel
meunier membre de l'association les amis
de la veille de la bière délégué pour le
plateau de saclay vous êtes ici chacun
car vous faites partie des 27
associations qui demandent un débat
public sur l'aménagement du plateau de
saclay le plateau de saclay je le
rappelle c'est le projet phare du grand
paris qui est un moteur pour le
renouveau
de l'industrie française et européenne
ce sera un pôle d'innovation qui
rassemblera 15 % de la recherche et
développement industrielle française
dans les hautes technologies
alors c'est un projet d'envergure qui
vont beaucoup de chantiers il ya mon
fils de logements prévus il vous
préoccupe d'un point de vue
environnemental c'est pour ça que vous
demander justement un débat oui merci
nous inviter d'abord parce que et nous
recevoir parce que jusqu'ici la parole
des habitants du plateau de saclay n'a
pas été beaucoup entendu et c'est bien
l'objet justement de notre demande de
notre saisine
alors c'est un petit peu technique de la
commission nationale du débat public
mais c'est une institution qui aurait dû
obligatoirement être saisie compte tenu
de l'envergure du projet et à cette
occasion là cela aurait permis
d'organiser un vrai débat citoyen de
présenter à la fois le projet dans toute
son envergure mais aussi des
alternatives et de voir ses impacts et
nous ce que nous demandons justement
c'est qu'enfin les citoyens soient
informés des vrais enjeux et que nous
puissions donner notre avis sur ce
projet qui est un projet colossal qui va
changer définitivement l'avenir du
plateau de saclay alors justement votre
avis a été laitiers si vous voulez
résumé gilles maignan quelques quelques
mots sur la plateau de saclay pour moi
c'est un espace déjà essentiellement
agricole qui
recenser des terres parmi les plus
fertiles d'europe qui a perdu d hectares
au fil des années et là avec l'opération
paris saclay il en perd encore 4 cents
donc les aménageurs prennent comme alibi
la création d'une zone de protection un
protection naturelle agricole et
forestière qui est sanctuarisé qui sur
le plateau même couvre 2300 hectares
mais il n'empêche qu'il ya 400 hectares
qui vont être sacrifiés à l'organisme
alors pour qu on explique bien des
inspecteurs c'est avant tout une
préoccupation environnementale
vous avez enfin moment forcément parce
que à la fois effectivement l activité
agricole ça n'est pas qu'une
préoccupation environnementale
c'est une préoccupation économique c'est
une préoccupation alimentaire nourrir
les franciliens avec de l'agriculture
proximité c'est un enjeu d'avenir
c'est une préoccupation c'est qui est
sociétale et social parce qu'on va
déplacer des chercheurs des salariés qui
sont bien installés leur wii sont des
grandes écoles par exemple plaisir
grignon les chercheurs sont très bien
installé à plaisir crûment avec des
locaux neufs et on va les déplacés sont
pas toutes s'appelait donc accroître
tous les jours des déplacements
contraints de la même façon les gens de
cachan vont venir sur plateau de saclay
donc en laissant plus des endroits un
petit peu je dirais les communales n'ont
aucune envie de faire partir de voir
partir c'est c'est magnifique centre à
la fois de recherche ou universitaire
donc à la fois ci les préoccupations
environnementales mais c'est des
préoccupations qui sont économiques
sociales des préoccupations qui sont
vraiment sur le mode de vie que nous
voulons avoir est ce que nous sommes en
paix avec la nature avec l'agriculture
ou est-ce que nous continuons à dire que
il faut au contraire continuer
d'organiser sachant que le projet
scientifique n'a aucune pertinence
puisqu'il est remis en question
maintenant de plus en plus sur ses
fondements scientifiques réellement vous
êtes d'accord vous n'êtes pas vous sur
le projet scientifique du paris saclay
êtres qui ne font pas pertinent
également monsieur noah le projet
scientifique c'est pâques
il est pas pertinent du point de vue
scientifique c'est qu'il n'est pas
pertinent du point de vue de son
gigantisme rassemblé soixante mille
étudiants
pratiquement en un seul lieu ça va être
ingérable
aucune université au monde n'a ce nombre
d'étudiants est l'argument disant que
c'est pour être mieux classé dans le
classement de shanghai
c'est stupide c'est stupide parce que si
on regarde ceux qui sont les mieux
classés à l'heure actuelle ils n'ont pas
60000 étudiants labarda 21 militants et
là on en prévoit 60 berkeley berthelet
on a 30 mais quand même c'est de la plus
grosse seconde mais le gigantisme de
cette opération et enfin et vos
démarches ne sont pas du tout entendu
vous avez déjà c'est créer un dialogue
justement mais nous avons déjà demandé
d'aider 2010 avant la loi grand paris
nous avions demandé au débat public il
n'a pas été obtenue est en fait là les
pouvoirs publics sont en infraction par
rapport à la voirie gosse aurait tube
obligatoirement faire ce débat public
parce que au-delà d'un certain seuil
économique c'est à dire 300 millions
d'investissements d'euros il était
obligé de le faire donc on est déjà dans
dans un des 1 dispositifs dérogatoires
vous avez justement solliciter le
gouvernement les membres du gouvernement
par rapport
nous avons dans un premier temps demandé
récemment à la commission nationale du
débat public de se saisir mais elle nous
a expliqué qu'elle ne pouvait
s'autosaisir mais que la demande était
pertinente elle a écrit elle-même et
donc nous nous sommes retournés vers le
gouvernement les ministres concernés
même l'établissement public paris
s'appelait alors où nous en sommes mais
c'est vrai que nous regrettons fortement
depuis des années personne ne voulait
entendre notre voix
vous comprenez a notamment que c'est un
sujet sensible parce que c'est un
le pointu paris saclay sera un événement
dont je majeur pour l'économie et pour
la vie étudiante enfin les étudiants
d'île de france
vous comprenez mais en même temps ce que
l'on dit actuellement plus on met les
études les chercheurs ensemble et non il
ne travaille plus dans la coopération et
non d'un concurrencer des études
internationales qui dix ans et même les
chinois maintenant commence à dire mais
c'est plutôt de rassembler les moyens de
recherche au même endroit parce qu'en
fait ce n'est pas ça qui est pertinent
c'est pour ça que je les ai tout à
l'heure que ce modèle n'est pas
pertinent parce qu'effectivement
maintenant on travaille autrement
à preuve même les microsoft qui était en
cours non très très près de la haye est
reparti dans paris parce que ça les
intéresse pas d'être dans soigne un dieu
tu es loin de la vigne est vraiment dans
un autre modèle maintenant et non plus
dans le modèle des années soixante dix
de la silicon valley
le projet cristallise aussi d'autres
tensions par notamment l'arrivée du
métro c'est quelque chose c'est un
élément aussi du coup pour le sourire
qu'on est opposés le métro moi je
l'appelle le métro deschamps c'est un
métro qui va relier d'accord le pôle de
saclay revenant de massy mais aussi
après saclay il va se poursuivre jusqu'à
50 en ligne sans aucune gare sur pylône
est justement bordure de cette fameuse
zone protégée dont je vous parlais le
trafic espérée entre 50 entre mais
comment le pôle de saclay et 50 en
yvelines ne justifiera jamais les
investissements et ne rentabilisera
jamais le fonctionnement de ce métro
sauf sauf sauf si une urbanisation
secret et ça pour le moment
tout le monde l'a ni d'entre nous elle
est presque évidente que derrière
derrière ça avance caché que la
tentation sera trop forte en ayant un
métro aérien qui qui longe le plateau
de construire des gars dans les champs
est de faire venir des habitants pour
rentabiliser ce métro là vous attendez
le débat là la prochaine étape est
justement de votre combat si on peut
l'appeler ainsi être effectivement à la
mi janvier 2016 enfin début 2016 un
nouveau débat public va être organisée
mais rien que sur le métro pas sur
l'ensemble du projet et là nous
soutiendrons la position que vient
d'exprimer michel meunier que c'était en
fait un cheval de troie pour
l'urbanisation que ça ne répond pas aux
besoins des habitants et qu'il y aurait
des solutions alternatives notre
notamment le prolongement de la branche
ces deux du rer c qui ré de massy à
saint quentin en yvelines sans arrêt à
versailles ce qui permettrait de relier
massy et saint quentin en yvelines avec
l'existant et d'améliorer aussi les
liens actuels et donc nous nous disions
via les projets alternatifs il ya un
téléphérique qui pourrait monter aussi
les habitants du côté de l'essonne sur
le plateau on a des alternatives nous
voulons que ces alternatives soient
elles ont déjà été étudiées et qu'elles
ne soient pas mises de côté au motif
qu'il faut absolument faire ce siècle n
18 pour un projet de prestige et bien
merci à claudine pareil michel meunier
d'être venu en plateau et d'avoir
répondu à nos questions
nous suivrons avec vous cette actualité
merci et face aux attentes
ou bien et au face aux atteintes aux
biens aux personnes qui peuvent être
causés par des animaux de la faune
sauvage
l'office national des forêts organise
une fois par an une battue
administrative une solution pour
résoudre les difficultés ponctuelles du
fait des grosses densité de population
d'animaux comme par exemple la
concentration de sangliers nous avons
accompagné ces chasseurs jeudi dernier
sur cette opération qui s'est déroulée
dans la forêt de la minière à huy en
cours un reportage réalisé par william l
il faut savoir lever la carabine
je pense que j'ai une bonne équipe et
c'est très sécurisant pour un directeur
de chasse et puis pour les personnes qui
les chasseurs écoutent attentivement les
dernières recommandations avant de
commencer la battue aujourd'hui la
chasse se déroule en milieu semi urbain
le maître mot et sécurité alors on parle
de chasse en forêt urbaine on met le
point fort sur la sécurité puisqu'il ya
toujours des gens en permanence chez
circulent dans cette forêt il ya des
routes de proximité il ya les
habitations anticiper les dégâts en
réduisant les populations de sangliers
pour ce faire les chasseurs se divisent
en deux groupes les tireurs qui forment
une ligne de tir en se postant sur des
miradors et les tracker qui rabat le
gibier jusqu'à la ligne de tir
le tout dans une zone entièrement
quadrillé pour éviter tout accident
ce sont des animaux qui font quand même
pas mal de dégâts déjà au niveau de
sécurité sur les routes
on a quand même quelques soucis de
collision un de risque de collision
donc même s'il ya peu d'animaux on
essaie au moins d'intervenir une fois
une fois un minimum une fois dans
l'année pour limiter la population au
maximum aujourd'hui pas de distinction
selon l'âge de la cible tous les
sangliers doivent être retirés
toute la journée les rabatteurs vont
arpenter la forêt à travers des chemins
plus ou moins praticables le chien joue
lui aussi un rôle indispensable
l'animal permet de débusquer le gibier
dans des zones difficilement accessibles
aux chasseurs fois choisir une ligne en
forêt urbaine il faut assurer la
sécurité et l'efficacité d'importants
loyers de balles de deux sangliers tués
formidable bravo allez on continue bel
bat là seulement les chasseurs reconnu
comme expérimentés participent aux
battues administratives pour éviter tout
danger supplémentaire à la fin de la
journée ce sont 13 sangliers qui ont été
abattus et distribué aux participants et
c'est le lundi vous savez le lundi nous
retrouvons sephora namani pour la
chronique culturelle bonsoir sephora
consorts florennes alors on a déjà parlé
plusieurs fois ensemble cinéma cette
fois ci on va s'orienter davantage sur
la bande annonce
ce week-end avait lieu la première
édition du festival de la bande annonce
à bois d'arcy
un festival qui a rencontré un franc
succès 300 entrées bois d'arcy qui
accueille les archives
du cnc centre national de
cinématographie depuis 1969 à
l'initiative d'andré malraux qui était à
l'époque ministre des affaires
culturelles et qui avait son festival de
cinéma mais qui vient tout juste d'être
remplacé par celui de la bande annonce
on a rencontré le maire de bois d'arcy
philippe benassaya qui nous explique
pourquoi
pourquoi la bande-annonce parce que tout
simplement cette agence un genre à part
entière au même titre qu'un clip au même
titre qu autre chose et puis en plus
c'est un genre unique
c'est ce qui fait le béaba d'un film
c'est à dire son résumé et c'est ce qui
donne aussi envie d'aller voir d'aller
voir un film donc c'est vraiment quelque
chose de très important et c'est un pour
nous c'est un c'est un genre unique en
france en plus puisque ce festival
existe cabré darcis alors genre unique
de la bande annonce mais est-ce que
selon vous florane la bande annonce se
conditionnent vraiment le succès d'un
film ou pas oui je pense que ça va en
vous comme de voir le film que ça
contribue fortement à son succès bien
écoutez nous sommes allés à la rencontre
de nos téléspectateurs pour connaître
leur avis oui ça oui parce qu'avec la
bande annonce on peut un peu tout vendre
voilà mais après ça veut pas dire que le
film il sera réussir parce qu'après
c'est la critique c'est à la fin du film
quoi mais voilà soju est forcément un
présentation selon les images
mais quelquefois c'est pas très fidèle
oui je pense parce qu'effectivement on
prend pas toujours le temps de lire les
critiques et de voir une bande annonce
ça permet d'aller beaucoup plus vite
synthétiser le film donc oui moi je
trouve ça intéressant peut-être diffuser
de manière différente mais sinon très
intéressante
bah oui c'est quelque chose d'ultra
important pour justement nous donner
envie après d'aller voir le film et son
sabre on n'a pas envie quoi alors pour
info la première bande-annonce date de
1928 pour le film l'argent de marcel
l'herbier et donc oui effectivement elle
conditionne le succès d'un film alors il
faut savoir qu'à ses débuts elle était
produite par les maisons de production
des films eux-mêmes
il peut depuis quelques années en fait
elle fait vraiment le le le socle en
fait deux
deux maisons spécialisées dans la bande
annonce donc c'est vraiment une
industrie à part et il n'est pas rare
que les grandes productions fasse
réaliser plusieurs bandes annonces
destinées à des publics différents
suivant les lieux de diffusion alors
qu'elle s'est un petit peu les
ingrédients pour faire une bonne bande
annonce assez fort alors les ingrédients
écouter et j'aurais tendance à vous dire
de base ce qu'ils vont faire qu'on aura
envie d'aller voir le film mais je vais
laisser vincent perrot pour les détails
techniques pour moi une bande annonce
c'est aussi une bande annonce qui fait
preuve d'originalité qui peut ne pas
aller directement à l'évidence et ne
vous montrez finalement que les bonnes
scènes du film
vous savez celle dont on se dit ça à
l'air bien mais est-ce que j'ai pas déjà
tout vu tout ce qui est intéressant dans
la bande annonce et qui finalement vous
donne pas forcément envie d'aller voir
le film
celle qui vous frustre un petit peu
parce qu'elle vous donne envie d'en voir
plus celle qui est original imaginative
pas trop vu voilà celle qui me donne
finalement envie d'aller acheter mon
ticket pour aller au cinéma
alors vincent perrot étaient présents
fait il a pourtant il n'est pas acteur
non il est pas acteur mais il faut
savoir que c'est un passionné de cinéma
il faut savoir que les 40 bande-annonce
qui ont été présentées proviennent
quasiment intégralement tout de sa
collection personnelle et pour
pour la petite anecdote en fait vincent
perrot a démarré à la télévision en 1980
pour monsieur cinéma junior et bien
écoutez comme quoi on en apprend tous
les jours car je ne savais pas est ce
que veut rien un exemple de bonne bande
annonce à nous présenter à nous
présenter ses forces alors une grande
annonce justement qui a marqué son temps
c'est celle du film itinéraire d'un
enfant gâté de claude lelouch sorti en
1988 et tout l'impact de cette
bande-annonce réside vraiment dans la
force de suggestion on se retrouve face
à un portrait de belmondo qui nous
raconte tout ce qui va y avoir dans le
scénario mais sans rien nous montrer et
donc justement le spectateur à cette
liberté d'imaginer le film rien et
spoliés on garde vraiment tout le
suspense on le regarde un extrait
certains regardent l homme en quête de
records de lalo
d'autant qu'apple regretter c'est quoi
ton équipe est la première dans le film
c'est richard laube année là elle me
laisse pas assez bon c'est la vie d'un
homme sur certains allez voir c'est un
bon exemple sephora ça rit ça donne
envie de voir le film merci beaucoup
vous retrouver mercredi pour un nouveau
numéro de kiosques un magazine dédié à
la culture et on reste ma culture on va
parler théâtre justement la compagnie
déclic théâtre présente demain à
coignières songe d'une nuit d'été
célèbre pièce de william shakespeare
une version toute personnelle présenté
comme la rencontre choc entre l'univers
du théâtre de banlieue et celui du
théâtre classique ou les friderici la
seule chose qui existe c'est vraiment
des individus des personnalités qui ont
envie de partager un moment ensemble et
je pense que il ya il ya cette idée que
le théâtre est une fête
le songe d'une nuit d'été une forêt
étrange un peu magique où se croisent
notamment couple d'amoureux transis roi
des elfes et rennes défait le vrai parti
pris il est de dire qu'en fait donc le
monde des fai qui est très présent dans
le spectacle de shakespeare vingtaine de
shakespeare nous on l'a transporté dans
le théâtre élisabéthain c'est à dire
qu'on a on a raconté que le théâtre
c'est de la magie et que la magie c'est
du théâtre
voilà en reprenant ce texte de william
shakespeare la compagnie trappistes
déclic théâtre entendait aussi permettre
la rencontre de comédiens professionnels
et amateurs plus d'un an pour aussi que
les choses mûrissent nature voilà donc
on a eu plusieurs séances de travail un
peu espacées pour que les choses
puissent un peu des cendres et être
digérée par les acteurs quand on démarre
un travail d'un texte on est tous un peu
on est tous un peu après on commence on
n'a rien on sait pas ce que veut le
metteur en scène
on n'a pas forcément tous les enjeux et
tous les tenants et les aboutissants du
spectacle après ce qui a été un petit
peu différent c'est l'appréhension du
texte c'est à dire que je pense que les
amateurs les gens qui travaillent avec
déclics faut beaucoup beaucoup d'impro
donc ils ont une expérience de la scène
et se confronte au public ça y'a pas de
soucis mais par contre effectivement
pour un certain nombre d'entre eux
c'était la première fois qu'ils se
confrontent est un texte et donc il ya
eu une petite il avait une petite
appréhension une petite peur à me des
petits blocages
la pièce sera jouée ce mardi 10 novembre
à coignières puis les 26 et 27 novembre
au prisme island et comme chaque année
avait lieu l'opération désherbage des
ouvrages à versailles alors il n'est pas
question de pelouse mais bien de livres
vendredi et samedi les bibliothèques
municipales ont mis en vente leur
surplus de livres au grand public des
ouvrages en double ou jugés trop ancien
pour figurer sur leurs étagères les
amateurs avaient le choix
plus de 10000 vieux livres cd ou encore
dvd étaient proposés au tarif unique de
1 euro du livre pour enfants au traité
de philosophie
après quinze ans le succès est toujours
au rendez vous pour sophie des listes
directrice des bibliothèques municipales
de versailles écoutez là ça a pris de
l'ampleur depuis trois ou quatre ans
parce que nos bibliothèques sont à
présent saturé et donc on a un flux
permanent chaque année on achète autant
de rage qu'on en élimine pratiquement sa
appeler beaucoup au grand public
précisément si on les vendait pas il
partirait à la déchetterie ce qui serait
quand même dommage parce que ce que nous
vendons sont encore de très bonne
qualité sont en bon état il ya des
classiques à delhi
de fond il y à des ouvrages qui date
d'il ya seulement quelques années et qui
intéresse encore énormément le public
je ne sais pas si vous êtes aussi
impatient que moi en tout cas noël
arrive à grands pas et l'opération le
courrier du père noël 2015 et lancer
cette année la poste ouvre son site
laposte.fr tirer père noël le 5 novembre
2015 et le secrétariat du père noël à
libourne le 17 novembre 2015
maintenant les jeunes internes aux
internautes peuvent directement envoyer
leur liste de cadeaux par mail au père
noël et c'est très pratique depuis 1962
la poste organise chaque année
l'opération du secrétariat du père noël
et à cette occasion les milliers de
lettres et courriers électroniques les
enfants que les enfants en vo au père
noël sous traité par son secrétariat à
libourne l'an dernier plus de 1 million
d'enfants des quatre coins du monde ont
écrit au père noël
alors n'hésitez pas il faut le faire
maintenant parce que sinon les lettres
vont arriver par centaines
c'est la fin de cette édition vous
restez avec nous tout de suite vous avez
rendez vous avec michael et demi d'euros
pour le 7-8 sport pour ma part je vous
retrouve demain à 18 heures pour une
nouvelle édition de 7,8 le journal en
direct je vous souhaite une très bonne
soirée